a gente vive a nossa vida inteira com
medo ninguém né que sair na rua hoje em
dia não é uma experiência tranquila
toda vez que a gente sai na rua ou
entrou no ônibus a gente desvia de
qualquer pessoa que se aproxime
quando a gente entra no ônibus a gente
se agarra na bolsa ou na mochila e deixa
mais longe possível de qualquer pessoa
ou se a gente a mulher
essa situação é sempre muito pior e o
que isso nos leva a pensar que vem dando
à souto que a polícia incompetente que o
estado não cuida de segurança enfim que
o brasil é o país da impunidade
mas na verdade o brasil é o quarto país
que mais prende no mundo atrás só da
rússia e dos estados unidos e da china
se a gente continuar com nossa taxa de
encarceramento em 2075 uma em cada dez
pessoas vão atrás das grades
comparando assim com a gente mais ou
menos umas dez pessoas daquela área ali
montada presas aqui umas 20 a outras dez
e por que isso acontece
o nosso sistema prisional
ele não resolve a criminalidade ele é
grave na lei a lei de execução penal
dispõe que a execução penal tem por
objetivo efetivar as disposições de
sentença ou decisão criminal e
proporcionar condição para a harmônica
integração social do condenado e do
internado
ou seja ela serve para punir e
ressocializar
mas na prática o nosso sistema só pune e
de tal forma que inviabiliza qualquer
possibilidade de reintegração social
preço
além disso ele extrapola a punição
prevista em lei que é puramente a
privação de liberdade levando também o
condenado dos seus direitos mais básicos
e sua dignidade tornando se também o
próprio sistema um criminoso por que
isso acontece
o atual contexto de superlotação
carcerária
o brasil tem em média três presos para
cada uma vaga nessas condições é
impossível que se mantenha uma
manutenção adequada que se possa criar o
projeto de ressocialização que se possa
empregar todos os presos
os condenados são obrigados a dormir nos
corredores em colchões patrulhadas
improvisar redes dentro das células
porque simplesmente não tem mais espaço
o tratamento é desumano e os próprios
trabalhadores dentro dos presídios
também vão viver nessas condições então
é praticamente impossível que eles
executem o seu trabalho de forma efetiva
a manutenção ea limpeza são muito
difíceis de se manter e então os preços
são obrigados a viver em ambientes quase
sem nenhuma higiene no meio do lixo e do
esgoto
a alimentação também não é não é válida
pratos são trocados por sacos plásticos
os talheres pelas mãos
então se entra um criminoso ele sai como
um animal
as próprias famílias também sofrem
aqui é a área de visitação e os
banheiros para visitação
ou seja também são as famílias unidas
não é só o criminoso
tudo isso causado e reforçado pela
negligência do estado que se recusa a
aceitar ea admitir que esses problemas
existem e se recusa a resolver esses
problemas o que permite o controle dos
presídios por facções criminosas que por
sua vez gera violência interna ou seja
para conseguir sobreviver lá dentro um
recém-chegado ele precisa se aliar essas
facções para conseguir apoio defesa e
manter as suas necessidades básicas
quando ele sai ele fica devendo favores
o dinheiro para essas facções que
deverão ser pagos em serviço ou seja
mais crimes
tudo isso somado com o fato de que
existe um estigma muito grande com os
soldados então é muito difícil um
ex-condenado conseguir um emprego digno
somado a isso também o fato de que a
maior parte da população carcerária é de
jovens que não completaram a educação
sem estudo sem trabalho e devendo
favores e criminosos
é muito difícil um ex-condenado não
voltar a cometer outros crimes
é quase como se não restasse outra opção
tudo isso inserido dentro de um ambiente
que animar lisa o ser humano despe ele
de qualquer noção do que possa ser bem
deixa apenas espaço para o ódio e da
violência
coisas que refletiram ea gente sabe que
refletem na nossa vida e na sociedade em
geral o que fazer para realmente
resolver o problema da criminalidade no
brasil seria preciso uma cruzada social
que atacar esse problema do ângulo
econômico social político de educação
mas uma das alternativas que vêm se
desenvolvendo é a parte da associação de
proteção e assistência ao condenado
ela anda se baseia em 12 pilares dos
quais eu vou destacar a participação da
comunidade o trabalho a família ea
valorização humana ou seja são os sites
pequenas como máximo 100 presos em que o
trabalho é obrigatório e que humano é
valorizado cada homem é maior do que o
seu é então se acredita que quando ele
sair ele possa devolver algo à sociedade
isso não é só uma utopia em 17 estados
do brasil isso já está sendo implantado
e já existe em 33 países
aqui são fotos dos de alguns trabalhos
são desenvolvidos por exemplo a padaria
que fabrica pães restaurar vidas orbitam
é toda feita pelos próprios presidiários
e por voluntários e dá para se pensar
que por está sendo feito por
seria uma grande bagunça mas na verdade
como eles são eles mesmos responsáveis
por aquilo que é deles e pela
recuperação deles
eles têm um sentimento de auto ajuda e
cooperação que acaba gerando o ambiente
de disciplina e organização
é aquela frase que todo mundo já ouviu o
bandido bom é bandido morto
a pac não discorda disso ela acredita
que é preciso matar o criminoso para que
se possa salvar o homem e para quem
ainda não entendeu direito que significa
no sistema tradicional
cada vaga o seu quatro mil e quinhentos
reais e quarenta e cinco mil reais para
se construir uma só vaga e o custo
mensal para cada preso é de mil e
oitocentos reais com uma retórica de
reincidência maior 80%
a gente está gastando muito dinheiro pra
piorar as pessoas na pac cada vaga e
quinze mil reais e um custo mensal de
cada preso e nove anos com uma taxa de
incidência menor que 10%
claro que a parte sozinha não vai
resolver todos os problemas do brasil e
não vai conseguir resolver toda a
criminalidade ea violência mas nós somos
jovens e estamos dando esse país e é
cabe a nós resolver todos esses
problemas ea gente não pode ter uma
postura cética em relação a isso a gente
precisa acreditar em projetos como esse
que acredito no ser humano e acreditam
no futuro pra que a gente possa resolver
esse país de forma completa
recuperando se da parte acredito que nós
devemos ser as mudanças que queremos
para o mundo
nós temos que também obrigado